no per caso tu hai peccato non ho
pescato solo con il pescato benissimo e
anzi non lo slime sono cose viola contro
come giorni con il crono di tutto in
certi di un giallo
abbiamo già fatto un video slime solo
coast e rosa contro tutto note blu e
abbiamo raggiunto i 10 mila mi piace
quindi come promesso eccone un altro è
fatto aiutare a voi quale colore
volevate mi ha fatto un sondaggio su
youtube e avete scelto viola contro il
già noto il verde c'era anche l'opzione
verde potevamo fare felice la vita anzi
quanti avete postato viola e giallo e
anche questo video raggiunge i 10 mila
mi piace ne faremo un altro e decidere
poi il colore di mettere presto detto
zico in cui potete scegliere così quello
che serve più voti andremo a farlo
nell'approssimazione per questa volta
poter votare nei commenti chi pizza alla
fine del video perché in fondo è già
stato occupato da un altro sondaggio è
qui dove farà ritorno dovremo pescare un
ingrediente bendati e alla fine qui
avranno sul più bello più viola nel mio
caso è più giallo del suo capre penserà
quelli di visite propri pretese patatine
imboccarne lasciate un bel mi piace e
notturno potete vedere qualche team i
crediti sono viola tutti gli ingredienti
di evitare sono gialli l'ingrediente che
non vi piace e tifo di una trasparente
ti si vede meglio il colore attendiamoci
dove la ragazza parlava anche di
limitare arrivo pescarese ieri è la teen
star apprezzato io prego martino cattivi
ha preso preso penso che sia uno shampoo
questo il testo vediamo come vi furono
partiamo bene fortunato io invece ho
preso uno shampoo viola è uno shampoo si
è uno shampoo per bambini e piola
beniamo con duemila santo viola quindi
che non è tanto viola perché mi sembra
molto chiaro trasparente
infatti alcuni di questi ingredienti
potrebbero non essere viola ha detto
potrebbe essere bianchi e di altri
colori
quindi se ci capita uno di un altro
colore saremo in svantaggio a turi
svantaggio vediamo di che colore era lo
vedremo assieme ok e cupa vediamo quindi
non farà nessuna differenza quindi io
per ora sono in svantaggio perché non è
colorato di viola
buffon è giusto hanno fatto la
confezione viola ma non è viola dentro
speriamo di beccare qualcosa di viola
dopo ora vediamo quello di vitale
per uscire adorato starace berlino che
come potete vedere sta cercando in tutti
i modi di salire perché anche noi vuole
partecipare anche lui poi line che
secondo te ho mischiato gli ingredienti
vendiamo solo il gioco
se sentite nei rumori strani e berlino
che gioca con il suo giocattolo via
[Musica]
accadendo la mano come sta accadendo la
mano che spesso è che ho preso mi spendo
si presume momento zona e io ho freddo
dei glitter trolley iphone
de corato per mi faceva cadere la mano
perché io metto la calabria che la
faceva cadere gestibilità elisa lunedì
pedoni dentro lo sai ma che si riparla
trasparenti e lo stesso non diventerà
viola
si sentono più perché io sono fortunato
eccoli qua sono bellissimi questi
glitter però non mi servono adesso
perché lo schema ancora trasparente
perché trasparente di ma se non lo
faccia diventare viola non vincerò la
challenge
va beh vediamo come diventa adesso
comunque che belli si devo dire che sono
bellissimi questi l'inter mai comunque
trasparente quindi finché non diventa
viola proposto vincere questo shanghai
che è diventato un trasparente opaco per
colpa di quello scopo di prima opa che
sfortuna in che perda gialloblù italian
super caldo con la polenta si è mangiato
partire un lingotto d'oro ma qualcuno
[Musica]
canfora un nuovo industrial rispetto
qualcosa di casa
prati cosa che ho preso non volete borsa
ha altresì preso nuovamente uno sa un pò
diverso questo però si chiama viola pino
di ben tre petali di è quindi forte
questo è veramente viola non lo ha
spostato la camera non vi preoccupate
lui se vedete che sta morena ministri
magari tu mi dici se secondo voi questa
sarà tanta era un viola oppure sarà solo
la convenzione come l'altro io spero che
sia davvero più altrimenti perderò
questa cia le vediamo la vita dimmi che
6 biasi prego e del 31 di bello e
fortunato da vedete più piccolo
[Musica]
meno male vediamo sono colora o se il
colore è troppo chiaro vediamo
[Musica]
la colorato ma pochissimo praticamente
ancora trasparente o devono essere
abbattuti qualcosa che non colori
vediamo quella di vita le due compagini
che lo renderanno ancora più bello
vi prego bello perché è bello per il
latte che imbiancheranno effettivamente
come la tua maglietta detto tantissimo
speriamo di rendere effettivamente molto
giallo mostarda preso allora io ho preso
qualcosa di piccolo spero che non siano
altri glitter altri miei ho aperto
questo addio non so che colore è ciò che
cos'è preso foglio liberato un foglio
che trovo affatto totale dato come torna
nel nucleare non rifugio fa tanti miei
interventi dei delfini band viola quindi
forte forte forte
riecco colorarlo viola fortunata abbiamo
fatto l'ha visto
il colore mi piace un sacco ecco qual è
il pigmento viola per fortuna ho beccato
dai divi che diventerà tutto mio loro
live e bronzo per questo vedranno
comunque in tirolo dire perché potrebbe
succedere veramente ma non si è colorato
tanto poi perché questo tremonti coloro
non capisca o un po di riflessi viola
blu però non è proprio un viola
abbiamo sbagliato un pezzetto ma in
questa piacere più grossi io voglio fare
più piccoli e chiarite le forme che vuoi
ma voglio fare di forma dà forma a forma
di fungo
come mai ha tagliate a forma di fondo
perché abbiamo detto polenta del footing
o di altre funesta forbicina guarda all
ideale per fare i pezzettini piccoli con
queste forbice devo stare attento ad
otto gli anni ordito come ideale devo
fare dei pezzettini un po più lunghi
così sembrano delle scaglie d'oro
coriandoli no dimostri le fila al timone
coriandoli forse quando la tv si ha
fortuna
sui bassi i pasti mi manca è bello non
barare euro controllati capitale non
bari 30 mar hanno fatto da sul numero
dai frati o per caso nuovamente qualcosa
che già il rumore mi sembrano cliniche
mi sa che io ho pescato male pero
bocciato il giallo
speriamo che non sia già una catena
bilancio barzanò è davvero giallo poi di
un altro colore secondo me no non è il
giallo è trasparente noi dobbiamo forse
trasparente speriamo il mercato delle
berline viola ma io do they come ratti
ma vediamo come ci stanno ma investire
che vuole il profumo stadi maligna
baruffa e olio idratante di argan
dr.jack quale mie per linee che non
faranno assolutamente niente per il
colore dello scalo
speriamo speriamo che non cadono una
volta che le attivo magari si farà
qualche suono
qualcosa però comunque rimane non viola
rimane un colore e un po strano sempre
più blu che viola
[Risate]
ma io voglio incamerato il viola dai
miti woods hole cercando vediamo di che
colore
[Musica]
anzi lotina speriamo che di più o meno
già 26 b troppo giallo un po troppo
incassando non è zucchero a mera
profumato che bello e buono legato allo
slang profumatissimo pulito e profumato
perché le prove e uno slide pulito
profumato l'ultimo torna a 1 io guardo
ai siamo per caso tu hai peccato non ho
pescato il suo nome non è peccato allora
mai visto tu no non ho capito o per caso
a si è preso qualche impresa dico io mi
sono preso inizio a che pro noi vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono enormi ma le mani vedere cosa ci
giravo come la fata che era qua si è
spostato dietro da quello che dispiace
se adesso questo l'assunto dopo
mischiamo adesso dopo puoi imbrogliare
quindi quello lo devi vettori dopo una
volta chiuso laimer tivo e speriamo
garavini ora io ci metto il mio color
ardesia uno di gm di grande milano la
sfortuna
ecco qua per fortuna un po di colorante
oddio ma dove sparito ecco
più o meno ex super bione anche fin
troppo viola attiva che bello per
fortuna è capitato il viola invece
vitalic lei dovrà metterlo dopo pensa
proprio parquet e osimo torna dal rumore
può essere un pigmento o dei clipper il
tumore mio è mio e tuo andata così ma
perche ogni volta barbera provento
guidare questi sono degli scanner in
barbagia naturale per quelli che ha
pescato io primo parmigiani che è così
sono più grossi di quelli che un pescato
io prima più piccoli che un perfetto
io prima è però pure io l'ho pescate
primi mesi ho passato i clip quelli
sottili per ora
ecco qua i glitter via ma che belli mi
metto tutti diventerà un bellissimo cane
non valore dell'arte insomma stando un
po sparendo però è comunque bello perché
sembra un galaxy con tutti i pianeti i
pianeti sono queste per linee partono
anche bene non vedo l'ora di vederlo
attivo proviamo ora il super giallo
digitale fammi vedere come prima
bracciali queste sembrano delle
magliette ma che rovinerà segreto che la
giusta perché questo è dorato
il player giallo quindi farà diventare
già logorato io mezzo proprio di sì
invece guardare
vedremo anche bravi ad attivare i nostri
giallo viola e giallo prodi 3
ecco quelli offline
allora mi piace un sacco perché
morbidissimo perché lo show così quindi
scappi la morbidità ho fatto un sacco di
tori e il colore superbia latenti amore
i suoni fmr va a teatro
[Musica]
super rilassante smettere con questo
perché supersport nuovi per con tante
bolle ma mio amore a quello di vitale è
rimasto tanto già lo presento bolletta
dorata mio bellissimo slime dorato gioco
caso è stupendo e che coating devo dire
che il colore da fratelli vittime già si
vedono anche in pezzettini di scaglie
d'oro e soprattutto l'ottimo dato un po
troppo ovviamente rob è il mio il mio
segno distintivo sempre molto attivati
però a dare davvero esubero al colore ed
è un post ardone lo sly uno stanzone
pauline fa mostarda momento è solo e
dimenticato qualcosa
ottimo intricata di mangiare mai
dimenticato il play off a corto di tutto
ma levy pasta organizza invece no
ha raggiunto ei prendiamo per settore di
clay lo mettiamo chiama farà troppo
guarda che lo migliora detto che
rischiamo il play truffa certo non è
giusto stiamo facendo il pane adesso
vediamo come diventa questo pattern e
quando mi ha kiesto secondo me gli sta
dando quel colore proprio bellissimo
e voi che ne pensate più bello anzi da
ho detto che ho migliorato anche il
formaggio fuso e formaggio fuso e
formaggio fuso e formaggio refuso ogni
anno altro che volevano sentire la
differenza e mio bellissimo slam viola
fra poco o questa perfetta è il mio
bellissimo slide to letta un formaggio
fuso ed è più bello il mio
[Risate]
allora votate chi legge non è mai
sporcato il mio io allora di la volenza
vinco io servizio vitale e votate che
altro colore volete per la prossima tale
in questo migliore aggiunge pino mi
piace quasi a significare per vedere i
nostri altri video e stato solo la buona
ragione per il preferito
ciao nel cielo brillerà perché
no
prezzo
ma arrivare
[Musica]